hello and welcome to quadriga DWS
international talk show coming to you
from the heart of the German capital of
Berlin
I'm Brian Thomas and today we're all
going to explore how journalists around
the world failed to graph Donald Trump's
pull were so many voters the New York
Times labeled him a lunatic and many
other journalists quickly followed suit
the man with no chance as he was called
is now president elect Trump he's
preparing to take power few in the media
saw it coming the question is why not
it's being called the biggest failure in
modern American journalism I'd like to
start out by thanking our guest today
for being here to help us figure out how
our profession went so very wrong and
hopefully to come up today with a few
solutions to regain at least some trust
from those who've lost faith in the
media our guest today Matthew carnage
Nick he's the chief editor for Europe
for Politico he's based here in Berlin
he says it is a myth that good
journalism failed the Trump phenomenon
was well explored and analyzed but the
ruling classes ignored the warning signs
many people especially elites are in
denial over the anti-globalization wave
sweeping the West Allen poster is a
political commentator Florida belt he
says Trump and the populist heart have a
simple trick unleash anger and hatred
serious journalists have a simple answer
stick with the facts they win in the end
and Ursula Weiden Feld is a business
journalist she's worked for top german
publications including the Financial
Times panels wat she says the u.s.
election shows not only the crisis of
Western democracy it's also shown that
journalists have lost control over the
news business
like to welcome all of you to the show
Ursula if we could start with you is it
that bad have we has the traditional
media have we lost control of the news
business at least we are beginning to
lose control and the oscillations out
some have some signs for that and that
is that social media was much more
important obviously much more important
for people to make up their mind on the
two candidates that people in the on the
country side thought that that there is
no place for them in in the media in the
west coast and East Coast media and
probably that journalists took down a
trump a long time as entertainment and
and not as serious as they should have
to take him seriously as considering how
he was connecting in the countryside
with the people you mentioned who were
ignored
basically math you'd like to get to you
your organization Politico you published
the Gallup poll back in September that
showed a full 70% of Americans had lost
much or some trust in the media didn't
that set off alarm bells didn't that get
you guys over Politico thinking we need
to get out there we need to figure out
what's happening with a 70% well I think
people are out there to be honest I
think that it's a myth that the media
failed here because there are reporters
all over the country it's a huge country
first of all I mean we're not talking
about Luxembourg here we're talking
about a country that is several thousand
kilometres wide there are 320 million
people and in the end it was pretty
close I think that now people are
looking back and there's all of this
self flagellation and the press saying
oh how did we get it wrong much deserved
maybe well but Hillary Clinton actually
won a not a full majority but she beat
Donald Trump in terms of the popular
vote so the national polls weren't that
wrong the polls in the individual states
were wrong but journalists aren't
posters you know we need something to
guide us through this process we are not
you know scientists we look at the polls
we look at everything else that's going
on but I don't think we were we were
even making predictions and if you if
you really look at the trajectory of
what happened
the campaign there were lots of ups and
downs just a couple of weeks before or
even just a week before the election you
had this issue with the FBI
investigation even though it's a lot of
reporting about that about what it would
mean for Hillary if she could still win
so I don't really understand why now
there's no we all got it wrong I don't
think people got it wrong at all
but maybe the reporters aren't where
they need to be out in the countryside
is as Ursula was indicating maybe
they're at the press conferences they're
at the demonstrations not getting out
talking to for example the Trump
supporters Allen like to move on to you
now we'll pick up that as well later on
just before we went to air we heard the
French leadership saying that it is
possible that the front nacionales
marine lepen the far-right marine lepen
could possibly win the elections in
France or the Trump phenomenon coming to
the continent has the German press grasp
the scope of the Trump phenomenon well
how can the German press grass the scope
of the phenomenon we don't even know
what the scope is I mean is Trump going
to up end the liberal world order is he
the peace maker with ie as The Economist
put it who's gonna you know who's gonna
end free trade reduce protectionism do
away with NATO help people like marine
lepen
rise to power which will destroy the
European Union is it going to be that in
which case you know I mean I'll be on
the right side of history because I've
written that but I do understand that
they're colleagues of mine who are
saying no you know it's it's he's going
to be contained the American
institutions are so very strong and the
point is we're all we're all pretending
as if the press the media were this
block and by doing so I mean if we do so
we are repairing trumps and the Penn's
propaganda it's not the the fact is that
within my own newspaper divert there are
very different opinions about what this
means and and so obviously has has the V
press have the media understood
Petrobras about did you know did I get
one else we were scrambling about trying
to find did develop go out and talk to
Trump supporters that is a big question
right now we're people reporting on the
Trump supporters were they out in the
countryside were they looking at
was happening ursula indicated that
that's the big criticism in america
right now
journalists fell down and doing what
they really do best boots on the ground
getting out and talking to people did
develop do that we had a whole lot of
people out there and I mean for instance
whenever it's it's not just Trump
supporters one of our reporters got
arrested in Ferguson Missouri talking to
sort of if you will the other side of
the phenomenon you know the black lives
matter phenomenon he got a he
experienced police brutality at first
hand and of course you had people out in
maryland's or all that far from
Washington DC and an end off Virginia
where where they were all we know
whether Hillbillies were and not only
our people I mean you read a book George
Packard he's a staff writer for The New
Yorker he wrote a book called the
unwinding but what was happening to it
happening to the American middle class I
mean it's not as if there's this book
hillbilly elegy about the same
phenomenon it's not as if we didn't know
it it's just that none of us thought or
very few of us thought this would be
enough to become president okay so we
missed that it's a Black Swan it happens
we also didn't know didn't see the 2008
recession coming which is actually the
reason for all this
we're not profits we're journalists we
report on facts as we see them we don't
report is important things though
occasionally I mean the weapons of mass
destruction this is the biggest thing
since then for me we didn't see that in
Iraq we don't want to focus on that
today but that's something we missed as
journalists certainly no one believed in
the American press fell down there okay
let's move on let's take a look now um
we've been demonized certainly by
members of the Trump campaign let's look
at how Donald Trump has demonized off
for his part of it the press and how
that has resonated that demonization of
the press with tens of millions of
Americans things our biggest obstacle is
the press they're so dishonest a
terrible
false stories all made up lies lies with
the high above misrepresentation that's
given me by the media I mean the New
York Times is disgusting and I'm not
just talking about CNN they're all bad
honestly they're all bad I don't know
what it is is it like inferiority
complex but the media which is one of
the most dishonest groups of people ever
ever ever you're ever going to me okay
that's quite a demonization um I don't
think it's fair personally but let's
discuss that in the round and first I'd
like to continue Matt with what the
Columbia Journalism Review said is that
this is the the greatest failure in a
generation perhaps in all of modern
American journalism they're calling it
the anti Watergate what do we need to do
to turn that around look I don't think
there is anything that we can do to turn
around III again I just sort of reject
the snared a narrative in if you look at
that video that we just watched I mean
who was taking that video where did
people see that they saw it on CNN they
saw it on Fox all these mainstream media
outlets that he's castigating there the
reality is is that they made him what he
is he should be thanking them now
because those are the people who
followed him around the country I mean
you said before we weren't out there
with boots on the ground talking to
trump supporters I'm sorry but we were
we were at all of these rallies you had
reporters Libas use in our own
demolition basically lutely you had
reporters getting spit on they became a
prop during this campaign where he would
say look over there you know look at
these losers from the media over there
and you had some pretty ugly things
happening at these rallies and I think
that's why a lot of reporters may have
thought privately and they wrote this as
well that well when the American people
see this they're going to be shocked and
they're going to be disgusted and
they're not going to vote for him well
the opposite happened and they liked it
and they did vote for him so I don't
think that there was somehow you know a
lack of information and you know people
are saying that the press fell down well
what what exactly were the consequences
of it I mean it's not that they were
pushing a Hillary narrative or that's
actually what
some people are saying is that they were
you know they were pretending that
Hillary was gonna win well if that's
true it didn't help because she lost
okay right Sheila what about the
economic model of the of the press in
America how does that fit in with all of
this I think that is one of the crucial
points because me media or the press
first like took Donald Trump simply as
entertainment they just thought he will
never make it he will never become
Republican candidate he will never
become president and that is that's
entertainment that brings us clicks and
commentaries and that will push our news
business and that was the first big
mistake media media made if I could just
say one thing on that there just just to
clarify that people did say that during
the primary but at the point where the
you know he was at the convention and
where he got the nomination I think from
that point on people did take him
seriously because he was underestimated
from the very beginning and people did
laugh at him but from that moment at the
convention where he was going to be the
Republican nominee she changed that then
they started to feature him and not to
feature him as a rule breaker as
somebody who lies but to feature him as
a candidate so that was the second
mistake though is that nobody started to
fortify everything he said at the first
from the first point that media were not
quick enough to just qualify all the
lies and all the the statements he made
they just thought we mustn't take that
seriously because it is Donald Trump
but Trump sells well isn't that isn't
that part of it I mean Allen what what
do you think you know here in Europe in
Germany what why did the the press take
in and embrace a Trump on one level the
economic level giving him so very much
coverage it was inevitable wasn't it
look um about taking Trump seriously
most of my colleagues from the very
beginning we're saying what an awful guy
how terrible I mean you know and my
reaction have to admit my reaction was
to say look it's the primaries he's a
fool there's they're always fools in
American primaries it's entertainment
yes I wrote that and I was wrong okay
but it's
error of judgment that one commentator
in one newspaper made and let them be 10
of those who made a similar other others
were onto him from the word go saying
that he's a misogynist he's a racist
these are this he's of that and he is
all of those plus he's a lunatic yes he
is the fact is he was elected now that
it can happen we the fact is we trusted
American democracy and I hope we still
do we trusted American democracy this is
what the system is for to prevent people
like that coming into power this is why
I've defended the Electoral College I've
defended the primary system I've
defended all the checks and balances
which is growing it out then we have to
be happy with the choice even if we
don't like it no we don't if someone
kept ourselves into the Oval Office and
appoints an all-right Canyon like Steve
Bannon to be his chief counselor then I
think we don't have to accept it then we
have to say ok it's war down to the wire
of course it is we don't have to accept
every stupid thing the American
electorate does I'm gonna have to accept
every stupid thing mr. Trump does I
think we need to take a stand here but
your politicians are gonna have to work
with them what they work with all sorts
of people America is still our most
important ally right and it's gonna
hopefully gonna stay that way it's not
in our power to stop him but but you
know we don't have to now somehow become
opportunists and look for silver linings
all over the place I don't think we have
to do that so if he says against you
know if he says that his chief enemy is
the press I think we should take him
serious they say you can you know if you
want a war you can have it
well he's not only gonna have a war with
traditional media there's also vlogs
blogs a lot of alternative media out
there that are very concerned with press
freedom and I like talked about that
right now is is there more competition
coming up from this that you've noticed
Matthew the vlogs the blogs of some
readers been going over there is that
were there clicking the alternative
media well I think that they're
definitely clicking there they're not
leaving mainstream media completely but
if you look at the run up to the
election it was quite interesting that
sites like Drudge Breitbart had enormous
growth in their traffic drug
to be you know a particularly a
right-wing side had something like 1.5
billion page views per month which is
extraordinary I mean this is not
prepared when I asked how many Politico
gets in a month I don't even know to be
honest I don't want to hide it's
available on the internet but it's it's
that is a huge number it's not 1.5
billion I can I can tell you say Drudge
is different than Politico it's a news
aggregator as long as links on there you
guys write your own OSHA's this
narrative this you know alt-right
narrative as people are calling it now
and Carl Bernstein of Woodward and
Bernstein Fame said that before the
before the election couple days before
the election said if Trump wins it will
be in large part because this alt-right
media like Drudge pushed him for so long
and reached so many people and really
played the same role that Fox News had
played in the past for other Republicans
so this alternative media this this
social media out there is you know a
social media and and these these alright
news sites rather have become a very
powerful force and yet people are still
reading traditional media and you know
we were talking about before the show
it's really interesting that Trump just
a couple of days after he won the
election he's back on Twitter and what
is he tweeting about he's complaining
about the New York Times you know so he
still cares about yeah I mean we're not
gonna have a lot of resources and and
you know we're very serious about our
profession so um the German press is of
course also doing some soul-searching as
Alan indicated right now after also
getting the trumpet on them wrong one
look at some of the headlines want to
also say that there's a lot going on in
Germany in this regard let's have a look
oh my god was the front page headline of
the week leads each side the tabloid
Bild wrote will survive him as well but
then he not cite imposed a question why
Trump why not Hillary Clinton and the
target Spiegel asked should we be afraid
Ellen let's pick it up with you Trump
supporters would look at that and say
there's an inherent liberal bias and
German media they're probably right up
to a point there's also an inherent
anti-american bias and German media
Trump confirms the worst fears of the
people I've spent most of my
journalistic life combating people who
think that America is now close to
fascism and could tip in that way all
the time people who think that Europe
should disconnect from America and and
and and move closer to Putin and all
sorts and that kind of stuff you know
people who were against capitalism
people who point to the against
globalism it's not so and have seen
hitherto America as the leader of
capitalism globalization and a liberal
model of democracy yes all that comes
out in some of these some of these
newspaper headlines and the trouble is
the point is for the news media in
Germany you're fighting on two fronts on
the one hand you have to say Trump is
not what we consider a true
representative of what America is about
at the same time we have to fight you
know those people are going to exploit
the Trump presidency to move Germany
away from America it's a difficult
position to be in a rock and a hard
place
okay well Matt you were following what's
happening both the German and the
American media did you see a big
difference well I think the German media
tends to follow the American media on
issues like this I mean I I agree with
Al and I think part of the problem
though is that the German media you know
Spiegel süddeutsche affected to a degree
they tend to take their lead from the
New York Times maybe and and so that's
sort of driving driving the story record
and it's also kind of you know their
their hopes in the back of their
and over who should win that said I I
think it's really worth remembering that
there was some amazing reporting during
this campaign the reporters in the
United States broke stories about
Trump's taxes for example they broke the
story about Hillary's email that wasn't
Drudge it wasn't Breitbart those were
their lies we hope with the emails I
mean yeah but the story was still broken
by but before before the FBI I think got
on the trail the story came out
initially in the American press so there
was a lot of investigative reporting
going on there and if you look at if you
ask yourself well what is really the
role of the press in an election like
this it's to hold these people
accountable it's to really explore who
they are what their records are it's not
so much to predict who's going to win
now all of those facts were out there
and the American public decided to vote
for him anyway and I think you know that
is really the story that people missed
if anything is that at the end of the
day they didn't care and you know people
you know they're always these
accusations of liberal bias I mean if
the Washington Post or The Wall Street
Journal or whoever reports on the video
that that was uncovered of Trump making
these comments about women and they
report it does that mean that they have
a liberal bias they're just reporting
what's going on in the campaign and
these are all relevant things that
people you would think people should
know ultimately they didn't care okay
well I like to say many people here in
Germany you could say also don't care in
a way they've they've lost faith in the
in the traditional media the accusations
include misinformation bowing to state
control censorship according to one
survey in for test emic de map 42
percent of Germans doubt the reliability
of their country's media these
demonstrators call Liars the mainstream
media no longer seem to be reaching
here the far-right pegida movement is
one example of that this protest targets
not only the government's immigration
policies but also the media why is there
such a disconnect ursula why do you why
do you think there's such a disconnect I
think media are considered in Germany as
in the u.s. as part of the establishment
as press which only transports and
commands on things the government wants
to be transported wants to have
transported and to be Co commanded and
that people on the countryside are not
considered as part of the society as
part of the public discussion as and has
not seen with their needs or with their
opinions and and that is the biggest
challenge media has to cope with in in
the next in the upcoming years
especially because even in Germany we do
have a far-right politician party and
then and they probably will be
successful in the next election so how
to cope with that how to discuss these
issues is are crucial even for for
German press and for German media while
coping with that it's going to become
much more difficult in January that's
when Breitbart arrives in Berlin it's
coming to Germany a gentleman version of
Breitbart does that have you worried
Alan do you seek competition there of
course yeah of course and what does they
said yeah about social media the point
is you have to have a lot of money in
order to have reporters journalists
working on things actually reading
reports talking to people and the press
is starved the media is starved for
money unless the state media like the
one where place were sitting in now
independent media like the outfit I work
for a starved for money have to cut back
on staff and so on so it's we're really
the Spiegel just announced that it was
not cutting staff and and and we really
have to see how how what people are
working my colleagues are working about
double what they worked when I tried the
paper honestly they're doing all the
jobs we had lay out as foreign all sorts
of things when when I says we're in a
really difficult position but we're
still the only people actually doing
that because people like Breitbart
they don't go out and research anything
they just
new reports from Russia today or from
anywhere else and they put them online
in a sort of post factual melange of
so-called news and people read that
stuff that means that that we the
journalists have to resist the
temptation to only look for clicks and
commentaries and the social networks
only are only gaining for just
entertainment and they have to become
serious again this huge amount of
readership
moving to social media is actually you
could say under attack right now by the
German government which is criminally
investigating Facebook's owner Mark
Zuckerberg is that the right way forward
to clamp down on social media with
government investigations he's being
charged with not removing hate speech
quickly enough German ministers are
meeting by the way today to draw up
guidelines that hate speech is removed
within one day is this the right way
forward that kind of government clamped
down let's ask Matt as an American I
Isis I understand the motivation behind
it I doubt that it will work and I think
that this is what the Germans will will
ultimately discover it's Facebook today
maybe Twitter tomorrow and then in a
couple of years something else rises up
the reality is is that Facebook isn't
allowing the stuff because it likes it
it's just it's very difficult to police
when you have as many users as they do
to take this stuff down in a timely
fashion or at all can can be can be
quite challenging so I think this is
unfortunately the nature of this online
sphere in which we live Twitter today or
yesterday announced as you know more
strong controls on this on this type of
thing and they actually shut down the
account of one particularly particularly
blatant racist preacher on there but you
know the the reality is is that there's
still a lot of very offensive language
in these in these social media maybe
will pick up that issue with our next
show how to deal with that on social
media we've run out of time and we'd
like to hear your ideas about what we as
members of the press can do better to
get this story right for now let me
thank our
for today Alan Ursula and Matthew thank
you so very much for being with us and
thank you for joining us here at quad
Riga as well remember get in touch with
us exactly about this issue what can we
do better thanks for joining us